YURI GRINSHTEYN: Welcome back.
During our last visit, we
worked with Stackdriver
to set up SLI monitoring
for application latency.
Today, we're going to see what
happens when our application
has a latency issue.
We'll diagnose and
treat the problem
and restore our
service back to health.
This is the Stack Doctor.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Now, you may recall that
the last time you were here,
we created an
alerting policy that
would let us know if the
latency of our service
went above our
desired threshold.
Checking in on it,
it looks like there's
an incident in progress.
It seems that there
is an issue that's
affecting our response times.
It's time to operate.
Now, before we start
cutting, we should first
figure out what's going on.
We'll use Trace to do that.
Let's switch to the Trace
list and get right into it.
There are definitely
some requests that
are taking quite a long time.
Let's pick one of
these and see what
could be causing our problem.
Ah, that explains it.
We can see that when
the request is slow,
it's because we're making a call
to the same service repeatedly.
This seems like a bug.
But let's compare that to what
happens when things are fast.
As expected, we're only
calling that service once.
Now we have enough information
to go back to our engineering
team and let them
know that they've
managed to introduce an
intermittent bug in the service
code.
Meanwhile, we'll roll
back the last change
and see if that restores
performance to what we expect.
The incident is resolved,
and our application
is healthy again.
I'm glad we sorted that out.
Now, you may be asking
yourself, Stackdriver Trace
sure seems great.
But how can I get my
service calls traced?
Well, let's take a look.
No matter which language
your service is written in,
it's easy to install Trace and
get your code instrumented.
If your app is in a language
that supports the Trace agent,
it's as easy as importing the
package and starting the agent.
Another option is to use
the OpenCensus library.
Now, you may recall that
this is the same library
we used for performance
instrumentation
the last time around.
If you would like a single
method of instrumentation that
combines both performance
metrics and tracing,
this is a great way to go.
And finally, lots of folks
like the Zipkin open source
tracing system.
It's based on the
Dapper research paper
that Google published
back in 2010.
And Google still uses the
Dapper framework internally.
No matter which instrumentation
option you choose,
you can use Stackdriver
as the back end.
It's great to have a consistent
way of analyzing tracing,
no matter where it comes from.
Now that we've covered
Stackdriver Trace and all
the different ways you can
get it to work with your code,
you'll be much better
prepared to tackle
any latency issues that may
come up in your own service.
Next time, we'll
profile the code
to figure out exactly
why a particular service
call could be slow.
That's it for this episode.
This is the Stack Doctor.
Stay healthy out there.
[MUSIC PLAYING]